بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول تعالى قالت الاعراب امنا
قل لم تؤمنوا
ولكن قولوا اسلمنا
ولما يدخل الايمان في قلوبكم
وان تطيعوا الله ورسوله لا يلدكم من
اعمالكم شيئا
ان الله غفور رحيم
قوله تعالى قالت الاعراب
الاعراب هنا
اسم جمع جنسي
ايش اسم جمع جنسي يعني ليس له مفرد
لفظه
الا بالزياده
فتقول اعراب جمع
اعرابي بتزيد عليها الياء بتصير مفرد ياء
النسبه
هذا
النوع من الاسماء في لغه العرب يسمى
اسم جمع جنسي
اذا زدت عليه نقصت من معناه
واذا
اخذت من مبنى زد على معناه
هذا العكس عاده لما بنزيد حروف بنزيد في
المعنى لكن هذه
تختلف مثل بقر وبقره
فجر وشجره
انس وانسي
وما شابه ذلك
والاعراب
الذين
يسكنون الباديه
الاعراب
لا يسكنون داخل المدن المدن ولا القرى
فمنلاحظ
في قول الله تعالى
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى يذكر
الرسل
فيذكر من صفات الرسل
نوحي اليهم من اهل القرى رجالا نوحي اليهم
من اهل القرى
هذه شروط للرسول وللنبي
فاول اشي الرسول يكون ذكرا مذكرا ليس ثم
رسولات ولا نبيات
وايضا يكون من الانس كما اسلفنا وجعلنا في
ذريتهما النبوه والكتاب يعني جعل الله
النبوه والكتاب في ذريه نوح وابراهيم
عليهما السلام
وكذلك يقول تعالى
من اهل القرى
القرى
جمع قريه الرسل والانبياء لا يكونون من
الاعراب يكونون من القرى
يكونون من القرى من المدن
التي
يعاد اليها ويرجع اليها
والاعرابي ضد المدني الاعرابي هو الذي
يسكن الباديه
بعيد عن المدن
وبعيد عن
المجتمع
الذي يكون اكثر حضاره
من انحاء
وطبعا الباديه لها
لها منافع
ولكن من ناحيه الخلق فان الباديه صعب جدا
على خلق الانسان الانسان
يتاثر بما حوله يتاثر بمن
يجالس وياكلوا ويشاربه
فالانسان اذا مكث مع
شخص فانه
سيكون على دينه
كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال المرء على دين خليله فلينظر احدكم من
يخالل
جلست مع احد من الناس
تفتحت له وتفتح ولك
فان هذا
يجعلك تتبعه في كثير
ويتبعك هو في كثير
وهذا خير اذا كان مع اهل الخير واذا كان
مع اهل الشر فهو شر
وهذا الكلام
لان الانسان يتاثر بما حوله
يتاثر بالاشخاص يتاثر
بالدواب يتاثر بالاجواء
الانسان مخلوق من هذا مخلوق من طين
ومن صفات الطين انه سهل جدا انك تاثر فيه
وكل ما كبر ومر على هذا الطين الزمان
يبس
وتصلب لكن خاصه الصغير في السن كل ما كان
اصغر في السن فانه متاثر اكثر واكثر بما
حوله وهذا شيء معروف
فالمرء على دين خليله
هل ينظر احدكم من يخالف
وحتى الحيوانات
التي يكون معها الانسان فانه يتاثر بها
جاء في صحيح البخاري صحيح مسلم الحديث
ابي مسعود البدري رضي الله عنه ان النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم ذكر ان
الكبر الكبرياء والخيلاء في اهل الوبر
اهل الوبر يعني
اهل
رعاه الجمال
رعاه الابل
يقول
الكبرياء والخيلاء في اهل الوبري والخير
والسكينه والطمانينه في اهل الغنم هذا
كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
هذا
غالب حكم غالبي
للواحد قعد مع الجمل مده طويله بصير ياخذ
من
تصرفات الجمل انا ادري هذا شيء قد لا
يتصور لكنه صحيح
الجمل الابل اذا نظرنا الى احواله
هو من ابرز من ابرز صفات
جمل الابل
نوم متكبر
ابر
في حقد
جمل اذا زعلته
ممكن بعد عشرين سنه يشوفك
ويستب ثاره وهذا بدون مبالغه يعني
جمل جمل
اصله حاقد
ومتكبر ولا ينقاد الا رغم انفه
ويكون بينه وبين راعيه الحرب سجال مرات
الجمل يغلب ومرات الراعي يغلب هكذا
الذي يجلس بين الجمال بده يبقى راعي الجمل
بده يبقى
فيه نوع من هذه الاشياء حتى يتغلب على
الجمل
فراعي الابل
يغلب فيهم الكبر
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم يذكر في الحديث
ان الخيلاء في اهل الخير
يعني الخيل تجد الفرس فيه نوع من الفخر
فيه نوع من المظاهر في نوع من القوه
تخلي
الفرس صافن وبتخلي الفرس يعمل ويسوي
الذي يجلس بين الخير
ويتصرف مع الحصن
فانه
سياخذ من هذه النفسيه
كذلك الغنم
يقولوا صلى الله عليه وسلم والسكينه في
اهل الغنم
سكينه في اهل الغنم
لان النعجه مسكينه بس بدها تاكل ما فيها
لا كبر ولا فيها حقد ولا فيها شكله
بتحاول يعني انها تطلع من من
حدودها لكن تنخزها صرا بترجع
وما فيها لا
تطاوش معاها ولا شيء والعاده انها ما تنطح
الا اذا كانت في حاله يعني محرجه
الذي يجلس بين
هذه ياخذ من سكينه الغنم
الى اخره وليس هذا معناه انه كل من راع
الابل صار متكبر وكل من كان في الخير
مدربا لها ساره
مختالا وكل من كان بين
الغنم فانه يعني مسكين
الدجاجه والصوص بذوق العشاه مش هذا هو
المقصود لكن المقصود الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم يوصل الينا في هذا
ان الانسان
بطبعه يتاثر
اثر بما حوله
اثر بالناس
ويتاثر
الدواب
ويتاثر بالجو
هذا الذي يهمنا من هذه الايه في هذا
يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في حديث
عند الامام احمد باسناد صحيح
من بدا جفا
بدا جفا ايش يعني هذا الكلام من بدا يعني
سكن الباديه سكن الصحراء
خارج المدن وخارج
جافا يعني بصير جافي في تصرفات وفي اخلاقه
بتصير اخلاقه حاده
والذي هو من الاعراب والذي هو من الصحاري
كيف الجو هناك الجو صعب جدا الليل
يكسح والنهار
حر بطبخ راس الواحد
وبعدين ما في نبات ولا في لين وكل اشي صعب
وكل شيء فالانسان الذي يسكن الباديه يكون
في هذا الجو وهذه الاجواء ويطول فيها
بتاثر في نفسيته فبصير فيه خلقه نوع من
الحده
وهذا قلما يستطيع احد ان
ان
يعني ان يفر من هذا اذا سكنت الباديه غصب
عنك بدها تصير هذه في اخلاقك
ولذلك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يمنع
الرجل ان يتشبه بالنساء
ويمنع النساء انها تتشبه بالرجال
ويمنع هؤلاء من لبس
هؤلاء وهكذا لماذا لان الانسان
اذا فعل شيئا في الظاهر فان هذا يؤثر فيه
الرجل لبس الحرير دائما بصير فيه ليون
وليون لا يليق بالرجال
وكذلك المراه اذا كانت
رجله من النساء
وتجد هذا يعني حتى في البيوت البنت مثلا
اذا بتكون وحيده ابوها وعندها خمس ست اخوه
تلاقيها بتقاتل مع البقاتله
وبتلاقي الرجل اللي عنده ست سبع اخوات وهو
وحده المسكين بتلاقي يعني
امور اسهل يعني فعلى كل حال الانسان بتاثر
بالاجواء اللي بيكون فيها غصب عنه ما في
حل
يرحمك الله
فهذا شيء ليس عيبا وانما يخبرنا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بذلك لماذا
لناخذ حذرنا من ان يمكث الانسان في جو لا
يرضاه الله في حال لا يرضاها الله سبحانه
وتعالى ظنا منه انه قوي العقل قوي النفس
لا يتغير وهذا غير صحيح
فقوله تعالى قالت الاعراب امنا الاعراب
هؤلاء قد اخذنا طرفا من خلقهم اصحاب وبر
وكذلك اصحاب باديه ومن بدا جفا
عندهم هذا الجفاء وعندهم هذا الاشياء
يفعلونها
فيها
جفاء وفيها وهؤلاء
اذا نظرنا الى الصوره بشكل عام السوره مع
هؤلاء الاعراب لا تقدموا بين يدي الله
ورسوله ان الذين ينادونك من وراء الحجرات
اكثرهم لا يعقلون
يا ايها الذين امنوا ان جاءكم فاسق بنبا
فتبينوا لا يسخر قوم من قوم هذه
اشياء صارت مع الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
في عام الوفود لانه اتاه اكثر من 80 وفدا
جاؤوا في هذا العام
يدخلون في الاسلام يبايعون النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وجمع من الباديه هذا قد
يبول في المسجد وهذا قد يكون
ينادي الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم كانه اي
واحد يعني وهذا ياتي يتفاخر على المسلمين
القدم وهذا ياتي وهكذا فهذه اداب انزلها
الله سبحانه وتعالى واخبر النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم في هذه الامور من هذه الامور
انه قال قالت الاعراب امنا هذا حصل مع بني
اسد بني اسد
جاؤوا
الى الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكانوا يعني يتفاخروا
انه
يتفاخروا اولا على المهاجرين الذين ليس
لهم نسب او حسب في المدينه او في مكه مثل
صهيب الرومي ومثل
بلال ابن رباح ومثل
فانزل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ردا على هذا
وكذلك قالت الاعراب امنا
هذا شيء عجيب لماذا
لان الاعراب هم في الاصل ابعد الناس عن
معرفه حدود ما انزل الله صح ولا لا
ام ابعاد ما شو بعرفهم في امور الايمان
والتدين حتى يقولوا هذا القول امنا
يعني استوفينا الاسلام والايمان واعتقدنا
داخلا
ويعني كنا فيه
الايمان اكثر من غيرنا هذا كلام يستغرب
عجيب قالت الاعراب امنا في الاعراب
هذا شيء هذا شيء بعيد
لذلك رد الله سبحانه وتعالى عليهم والله
عز وجل يقول
الاعراب اشد كفرا ونفاقا واجذر الا يعلموا
حدود ما انزل الله على رسوله
اجدر يعني احق الناس بان يكونوا جاهلين
بحدود ما انزل الله على رسوله
الاعراب اشد كفرا ونفاقا بعض الناس يظن
الاعراب بمعنى العرب وهذا كلام غير صحيح
الاعراب الذين يسكنون الباديه هؤلاء
هؤلاء
فيهم يغلب عليهم الكبر والحقد والجفاء
وهذه الصفه
فهم في طبعهم من ابعد الناس عن
الديانه وعن الايمان بطبعهم
زد على ذلك انهم ابعد الناس حالا عن
الايمان لا بيعرفوا يكتبوا ولا عندهم
تعليم مثل ما يكون في المدن
فهو يقول قالت الاعراب امنا هذا اصلا شيء
غريب
الله عز وجل يرد عليهم انهم يمنون على
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم شوف الناس دخلوا
بالسيف احنا اجيناك وبايعناك بدون قتال
كانهم يمنون عليه
الله عز وجل يرد عليهم هذه الاشياء فالامر
الاول قالت الاعراب امنا يعني يستوفينا
مراتب الديانه العليا
العاليه قل
يعني يامر النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في
الرد عليهم وعلى هذا وعلى هذه النفسيه من
مدح النفس وما شابه فلا تزك وانفسكم
الانسان اذا هل يجوز له ان يقول انا مسلم
نعم لكن هذا
اليس فيه
مدح انا مسلم فيه فاخر صح لكن على حسب
النيه اذا كان المقصد
انا مسلم
بالتعريف يختلف عن انا المسلم
كذلك انا مؤمن هل يجوز
يجوز للتعريف
انا مؤمن يعني ضد الكافر لكن للافتخار على
الغير فلا فلا تزكوا انفسكم
هكذا يقول ربنا سبحانه وتعالى
فالله عز وجل يقول قل لم تؤمنوا ولكن
قولوا اسلمنا ولما يدخل الايمان في قلوبكم
فهنا فرق الله بين الاسلام والايمان واحنا
ذكرنا سابقا ان الاسلام والايمان من
الكلمات التي عرفها العلماء
بانها اذا اجتمعت اختلفت واذا اختلفت او
افترقت واذا افترقت اجتمعت
تعريف عجيب يعني اذا اجتمعت افترقت واذا
افترقت اجتمعت هاي العلماء يقولون
ايش معنى هذا الكلام
ان اجتمعت
ذكرا في نفس السياق
افترقت في المعنى صار الاسلام له معنى خاص
والايمان له معنى خاص لكن اذا افترقت ذكر
الاسلام وحده او ذكر الايمان وحده
فانها تجتمع في المعنى كان الاسلام اذا
ذكر وحده معناه الاسلام والايمان والايمان
اذا ذكر وحده يتضمن الاسلام والايمان
وهذا كثير في القران مثل الله هو الرب او
مثل
البر والتقوى او الاثم والعدوان او مثلا
الفقير والمسكين او مثلا الرسول والنبي
عند كثير من العلماء وهكذا بل افرد في هذا
بعض العلماء
رسائل وكتبا يحررون هذه الكلمات
على كل حال العلماء لهم اقوال منهم من
يقول الاسلام والايمان بنفس المعنى وهذا
قول فيه ضعف
بنفس المعنى ايش يعني شرعا شرعا الاسلام
والايمان نفس الشيء طبعا لغه في فرق لكن
شرعا
نفس الشيء وهذا
ضعيف هذا قول ضعيف
وهذا هو راي الامام
الطحاوي رحمه الله في
العقيده عقيده طحويه هو
يفهم منه من كلامه هذا الفهم وهذا ضعيف بل
الذي عليه الجمهور ان الاسلام والايمان ان
كانت في سياق واحد كان الايمان
للاعمال القلوب للامور الخفيه والاسلام
للامور الظاهره من من الدين وان افترقت
يعني الايمان وحده او الاسلام وحده فانها
تجتمع في المعنى
فاذا يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى مثلا
وبشر الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات هذه ايضا من هذه
الكلمات
يعني امنوا وعملوا الصالحات في نفس السياق
مع بعض هكذا
واقترنه
فانه يعني بذلك سبحانه وتعالى امنوا
صدقوا بقلوبهم وجزموا وامنوا بالامور التي
يجب الايمان بها وعملوا الصالحات بجوارحهم
لكن ان جاء الايمان وحده وبشر الذين امنوا
ان لهم قدم صدق عند ربهم
وبشر الذين امنوا طيب
مش شرط انهم يعملوا الصالحات لا
الصالحه من الايمان
وهو ذكر الايمان وحده يقتضي ذلك العمل
الصالح
كذلك لو قال الله سبحانه وتعالى
انه مثلا يقول
ان رحمه الله قريب من المحسنين ان رحمه
الله قريب من المحسنين
المحسن هل يدخل في ذلك الامام نعم هل يدخل
في ذلك الاسلام نعم من باب اولى
فالله عز وجل فرق بينهما هنا لانه ذكر
الاسلام والايمان في نفس السياق فهم
يقولون قالت الاعراب امنا
قل لم تؤمنوا
يعني الايمان ما انغرس في قلوبكم حق
الغراس
لسه في زمن طويل
امامهم حتى
ينغرس الامام ينغرس بذره الايمان في
القلوب
وبعض الناس بعض القلوب اللينه فان هذه
البذره
يغرسها الله سبحانه وتعالى بسهوله
واما من كان
في جو صعب في خلق صعب في كذا صعب فان هذا
قد يطول هذا الامر
فهو يقول قل لم تؤمنوا
يعني لم تستكملوا الايمان بعد وان كان
عندهم شيء من الايمان شيء من التصديق ولكن
قولوا اسلمنا يعني انقذنا ظاهرا
ظاهرا انقذنا
لكن الايمان هل دخل الى قلوبكم حق الدخول
يقول
ولما يدخل الايمان في قلوبكم لما
هذا معناه انه الى وقت الكلام ما حصل
هذا معنى لما
يعني اذا واحد قال هل اتى فلان هل جاء
الشيخ تقول لما ياتي ايش يعني لما ياتي
يعني الى هذا الوقت وقت الكلام ما جاء
ففيه نفي
لكن نفي الى وقت الكلام
فرق بينه وبين لم لم ياتي قد يكون لم ياتي
امس لكنه اتى اليوم لم ياتي
قبل لكن اتى الان ما شابه ذلك لكن لما
ياتي فهذا فيه نفي لجميع الماضي
الى وقت الكلام ولما
وهذا ياتي في مثل قول الله تعالى
ام حسبتم ان تدخلوا الجنه ولما يعلم الله
الذين جاهدوا منكم ويعلم الصابرين
يعني بدكم تدخلوا الجنه ولسه الى وقت هذا
الكلام الله عز وجل لم يمتحنكم كما ينبغي
ليرى ويميس الخبيث من الطيب
فكلمه لما هذا حرف نفي وهو نفي
للماضي الى وقت الكلام كذلك لما
العلماء يقولون حرف جزم ونفي وقلب
ايش يعني
جزم ونفي وقلب
كلام حلو
لما حرف نفي جزم ونفي وقلب
اول شيء نفي شرحنا هذا المعنى وجازم
لانها تجزم
الفعل الذي ياتي بعده ولما يدخل هكذا
وهو حرف قلب بانه يقلب
المضارع الى ماضي
صح ولا لا يعني اصل كلمه يدخل يدل على
الوقت الحاضر او يدل على المستقبل هذا
اسمه فعل مضارع
وسمي مضارعا لانه مماثل
للاسم اسم الفاعل اسم المفعول
فهو يقول مثلا اذا قلت يدخل
يدخل هذا معناه انه الان حالا وقت الكلام
يدخل او سيدخل
هذا ايضا قد يكون هذا لان المضارع لايش
للمستقبل او للحال لكن لما انا اجي واقول
لما يدخل حولت يدخل الذي هو للحال او
المستقبل قلبت الى فعل ماضي صار معناه فعل
ماضي هذا اسم اسمه حرف قلب
يقلب المضارع الى ماضي فهو قال ولما يدخل
الايمان في قلوبكم وان تطيعوا الله ورسوله
لا يلدكم من اعمالكم شيئا
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى لا يلدكم اي لن
ينقصكم من اعمالكم شيئا سبحانه وتعالى
نطعت الله اطاعت الرسول فان الله لن يضيع
الاجر
لن يضيع اعمالنا
يلتكم يعني ينقصكم من اعمالكم شيئا يوفيكم
اياها
ان الله غفور رحيم فهو يوفينا جميع عملنا
ويغفر لنا ذنوبنا وما اقترفنا
والا فليس لاحد ان يفرض هذا على الله
وانما هذا امتنان من الله فالله عز وجل
يقول هم يتمادحون بانهم قد امنوا والايمان
لما يدخل في جذور قلوبهم لكن اخبرهم ان
السبيل الى الايمان والعمل الصالح وان عمل
الصالح بمعنى طاعه الله وطاعه رسوله صلى
الله عليه وسلم ان اطعتم الله واطعتم
الرسول فانه لن يلدكم من اعمالكم شيئا
سبحانه وتعالى لا ينقصكم من اعمالكم شيئا
ان الله غفور رحيم يعني الله سبحانه
وتعالى يغفر الزلات ويرحم
اصحاب الهفوات ان تابوا الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى او ان توجهوا الى الله هذا هو
غدا ان شاء الله الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين